I don't invoke aliens for any of the
ancient civilization stuff but I'm I'm
like
pretty conv I mean I think it's a
mathematical certainty that other life
exists in the universe but you said it
was humans that have left the planet
correct oh you're you're isolis is this
on the concrete podcast yeah
it's yeah possible well this so this is
and there's there's some other people
it's an interesting Theory I wouldn't
say it's my theory but yeah it is there
it is possible to analyze some of the
historical uh accounts yeah that there
may have been an exodus and some of this
may have even been depicted in some of
the Egyptian temples and in stories
uh that that it could be taken in that
life that yes there may have been a
branch of humanity in the past that left
so would that be the first oh yeah okay
if we're having fun pretty younger
driest Some Humans could have escaped
Earth yep and that's why alien
civilization or technology alien
technology is so much more advanced it's
just these humans from pre-younger
driest have built the pyramids who got
the out and now we started over
head start
yeah yeah we're just the guys who left
and had to start over and they're out
they have all their technology
dice all the fireball coming yeah and
they're like well no part of this we're
going we're gonna yeah if out of here
maybe we'll come back when the weather's
nice again that's the crazy part only
some of them made it off too yeah the
rest of them just had to wear that
yeah I did yes yeah you want to win
the lottery in that case it's like yeah
all right is your support your social
security number do you think that's the
obsession with uh space travel now you
think that Elon and some of these guys
they know that it's only a matter of
time before comment comes and they just
want to be ready to be out there I you
know Elon is interesting in that he does
seem to have this awareness of these ice
ages and cataclysms and stuff and I'm
sure look we're getting better at it
like we are we did the dot Mission
recently and you see that where we we
fired off a probe and actually tried to
deflect like a a um oh yeah yeah we just
moved it like a 15th of a degree or
whatever and and enough to think all
right theoretically we could probably do
something about this so we're starting
to put some resources towards it people
do understand it uh back when there was
space force and Colonel Matt lomai was
running it
um you know he was going to get Randall
Castle in to talk to those guys about
catastrophism so I'm sure people are
looking at it yeah but and that's the I
guess that's the long-term goal for some
of the space guys I don't know I don't
mean that makes sense if it happens
this regularly and it's this
catastrophic why would we not you know
put some resources to order yeah yeah I
mean I just the whole alien thing now
it's it's like I don't think we need it
to justify the stuff in the past you
know what bobblazar said on Rogan was
interesting one of the things he said
was well one of the aircraft came from
an archaeological dig so this is
possible this stuff's been going on for
a long time I don't see why not it's
you know there's it's an awful lot of
space and time out there you know for
that overlap to happen we we kind of
think of things in our long term as the
span of a human life it's not very and
you know in terms of the rest of the
universe it's nothing it's you know
you've got a it's a blink billions of
years and almost infinite distances and
to have two civilizations kind of peak
and cross over and and match each other
as
is uh it would be a it would be a
coincidence but mathematically it's
almost certain that life exists right
the Kepler missions when they they did
that and they started to look at
like what where they found planets in in
the Goldilocks zone around Stars they
started to analyze the shadows in front
of stars and they could determine like
the the distance of some of these
planets and they thought they wouldn't
find them very much but then they just
do excess like planets are in Goldilocks
zones everywhere so if you could explain
the Goldilocks well it's the distance
where a planet's orbiting like a like a
habitable solar system with a sun that
works for us and you're in basically a
Zone where liquid water can exist yeah
right because you're either 200 balls
off or you're too cold and stuff and so
there's a little Goldilocks zone like
worth is where you have liquid water and
everything we know about life is you
know requires that as a basis for it and
then whatever else takes place to start
life and evolution and I mean if they
find one skerrick of bacteria or
something on mars or or even something
else in this Titan for example in this
solar system I mean that's that's Case
Closed if you find life in more than one
astral one body in one solar system it's
everywhere forget it